Let's go. Where are we going next? Let's
go to let's go to Catherine g.G. I don't
know what if that's a location? What
is Catherine? Is that where you are?
Hello. Yes, hello.
Hi, yes, I'm from Arkansas, but I go to college
in Tulsa, Oklahoma. Oh, OK, very good. So I've got
a question about Trump's coming, a CPAC speech.
Yes. So I know there's going to be like
some news that kind of he might announce
is twenty, twenty four candidacy, like I honestly
don't care about that. I don't care what he has to
say about like twenty twenty two either, because,
you know, with the ongoing legal investigation,
something might happen before. Right. But
what I'm most what what I'm worried about
is like if he's going to say anything about
the Supreme Court ruling on his tax returns.
I know he's already I know he's already
had a statement in response to that, but.
Well, what are you what are you worried
about? What would he say that worries you?
Like, I like I don't know what he
could probably, like, be spreading
some y y y. I know this is hypothetical,
it's overexaggerated, but you know what?
Like how predictable is he, honestly? You know,
like, he's always got targets such as the media
and the Democrats and like. You know, like the the
court system, like he like he thinks everything
is rigged against him. What do you think he
could, like, start spreading conspiracies
about how unfair the court system could be?
Oh, it wouldn't be that he starts. I mean, any
time a court has ruled against him, he either, you
know, I mean, it goes back to attacking that judge
in 2017 and saying the judge couldn't couldn't
fairly rule because his parents are Mexican. So,
of course, Trump will do that. I just don't think
that it's a particular concern. I mean, he's an
ex-president. Yes. He's going to speak at CPAC on
Sunday. I think the most impactful thing he could
do would be to announce his 2024 candidacy. He'll
probably rail against who knows who for treating
him unfairly. I think at this point, we all expect
it. I don't think it'll have much of an impact.
OK, well, I'm just curious, because, you
know, like if these legal investigations,
like if something does really come up,
like he is convicted and possibly sent to
prison for whatever charges are
entails, not going to happen.
Well, like, well, what about, like, his followers
in the case that something like that happened,
like what would they do from
Trump's just not going to prison?
I mean, I don't know that it
even is worth hypothesizing.
OK.
All right, sorry if that's like an overexaggerated
or hypothetical thing, but no, no, I mean, it's
good it's good to think about these things.
Just the US doesn't jail past presidents.
And I just don't you know, people have asked
that off and on for the last year.
I don't think it's going to happen.
OK.
All right, well, thanks for reaching out,
David. Yeah, thanks, Catherine, very much.
Appreciate the call. Kathryn from
Arkansas in Tulsa. Very, very exciting.